I'm at a point now where I think I dislike MAGA and the anti-Democratic
Party online left. I think I dislike them about the same. Why
does he just always say things that like functionally disqualify
him from the job that he has? There's like so many different
dimensions along which Hutch's analysis is completely fundamentally
broken. You can't even think of all of them. It's just broken
top to bottom. It's awful.
All right, Hutch Hutch had a whole rant apparently about the
left today. Oh, apparently Oh, he's covering Apparently he's
covering Destiny. Very cool.
Apparently Destiny is re-watching the Elissa Slotkin thing. Again.
Oh my god, we're we're stuck in the same loop forever. We're
stuck in the same loop forever. This is 9 hours ago. And so what
I'm curious for your view on is while, [clears throat] you know,
I would love to debate you on your health care policy. I think
we need Medicare for all, you think public option, your housing
policy, etc. I'm just being really real with you. I want to talk
about Israel. I don't really hear what you say if you are still
supporting a genocide in Gaza. And that's for me. Do you see
I mean the framing, the framing, you know, like the question
itself is an accusation.
The question itself is is her saying you support a genocide.
Could you just I Yes, but is it inappropriate framing? Do you
think that it's not a genocide happening? Do you think when she
talked to Elissa Slotkin here, do you think it was not a genocide?
Is the Is the framing inaccurate? Or did you want an inaccurate
framing because they're talking to a Democrat? Do you Just say
that you want them to lie for the Democrat. If that's your position,
just say it. Just say, please lie for the Democrat. I would appreciate
if you guys lied for the Democrat. That would make me happy if
you guys lied for the Democrat. Right? Just say you want them
to lie for the Democrat. And then we're all good. I mean, talk
about hostile, you know, like this is more This is more hostile
than if Elissa Slotkin went on a Fox News panel or >> You know,
I'm speaking for myself, but I know there are millions of other
people who feel the same. Yeah, because again, just not engaging
with the material reality. I How can you How can you do this
don't engage with the reality at all? Like yeah, Fox News would
be fine with funding a genocide. Fox News is basically totally
fine with funding a
You're You're saying if she went on Fox News, they wouldn't even
be mad that that this woman was okay and and like voting yes
on genocidal
funding of the Israeli state, funding of the genocidal Israeli
state. I Funding and military aid that are explicitly used to
further the genocide that's happening. Right? Yeah, if they go
on Fox, they're not going to get questioned on this. Everybody
loves that at Fox. Is she a leftist or populist slappulist? She's
a populist. Sorry, I need to go back. So, I I actually think
Alyssa's
uh not Alyssa, Crystal Ball's politics are even more left than
Kyle's. Like I think she is definitely
a Marxist. Mhm. And I don't know what I'm trying to think of
where Crystal Ball I've seen her talk enough that I could say
she was a Marxist. I've seen her talk about Israel-Palestine,
but I do think it's really important that people disconnect this
idea that being pro-Palestine
or anti-Israel or an anti-Zionist means you're a Marxist or a
These things are totally disconnected. They are unrelated concepts.
And I just I wish people would stop trying to connect them together
because it does feel like you're trying to red scare people into
supporting Israel when you do that. What Regardless what Hutch
is doing, that's how it feels to me. You're trying to do a red
scare to get people to support Israel. Why not just talk about
why you should support Israel? Instead of trying to go, oh well,
actually this person's like a a Marxist and they want to destroy
America and that's why like I wouldn't take anything they say
seriously.
It's very silly. Just cross this sort of moral threshold. And
what it indicates to people and I think part of why, you know,
Zoran won so many people in By the I actually don't know Could
anybody explain to me
Maybe am I weird?
I don't watch people I agree with like
for for like to criticize something. Like I would never do this.
>> Just in a Immediately the framing of this is bizarre
to me. That you agree with Destiny and so you're going to go
watch Destiny's take on this instead of just watching the interview
yourself and giving your own take. Why? How do you differentiate
yourself? How are you giving people something unique?
You know what I'm saying? Like I just don't get it. It doesn't
make any sense to me. From a from a professional standpoint,
what are you adding here? What is the point of what you're doing?
New York City young people are >> Yes, I know. I know he's
letting he's letting his audience watch their favorite streamer.
I know. I know. You're willing to take the heat on an issue that
is really difficult for you where you're being overtly smeared
as an anti-Semite semi. And number three, there's no, you know,
entrenched interest that's going to control you. You have a spine,
you have principles, you're willing to stand up for something.
And so, you know, I'm curious for your reflections on that because
of your voting record and where you've stood on this conflict.
>> Yeah, well,
She's asking her like, is your conscience clear? Um
Who do you Where did you write that lights? Which one do you
hate more, tankies or MAGA content creators?
Oh, no.
Tankies or MAGA content creators. Think Ogre Boy or Tim Pool.
Um I'm at a point now where I think I
MAGA and
the anti-Democratic Party online left. I think I dislike them
about the same. Why does he just always say things that like
functionally disqualify him from the job that he has?
Why does he just repeatedly say things that are totally disqualifying
for the job he currently holds?
That seems really counterproductive.
If I just came out here and I'm like, dude, I like can't analyze
situations. I like can't think critically. And it really sucks.
It's like, bro, you're the guy who's streaming, who's analyzing
these situations and helping these people who don't want to take
all the time to think about this stuff. What? Why are you just
out here advertising that you have no idea what you're talking
about?
One is totally destroying your country, totally destroying the
economy. The
makes fun of you sometimes. The other makes fun of Democrats
sometimes. The other is really invested in in Israel versus Palestine.
But But let let me just remind you that the first one I talked
about is having massive tangible effects on millions, tens, hundreds
of millions, in fact bordering on billions of people. I Let's
just say it, billions of people.
It doesn't matter how how much you hyperbolize Hasan's influence
or anybody adjacent to him, it's not close. IT'S NOT EVEN A LITTLE
BIT CLOSE.
It's not a little bit close.
For years it would have been MAGA,
but I I I've been I've been so pushed over the line. I've just
I I have endured this now.
I've endured it. Oh my god.
>> Dude, I've endured this now. I've endured the terrible
harassment these people do things like saying I'm dumb and pointing
to the faces I make. I've endured this harassment for far too
Dude, seriously,
I Man, it's so it's such And at at a base level again, real tangible
effects.
Right? The real tangible effects of MAGA and the the effect they've
had on everybody and you apparently right before midterms are
like, well, actually the online left, they're about as bad as
MAGA. Yep. Yep. Yep. IT'S INSANE. IT'S TOTALLY INSANE. IT'S AN
INSANE THING TO SAY. He should feel embarrassed for saying this.
How is nobody in his chat calling him an embarrassing loser for
this take? You are completely
I This is This is just It's now it's spite based for him, too.
He's completely detached from reality.
I Here's the thing. Here's the challenge to Hutch. The real challenge
to Hutch. Go and make this argument in front of
Okay? Next live and learn, go and make this argument in front
of Pisco and watch him pull that pull that baseball bat it out
again and terrify you with it, okay? He's going to pull that
baseball bat out and he's going to walk around the room tapping
it on the ground and you're going to piss yourself and apologize
for ever thinking this stupid [__] that you say on
your stream. That's how that's going to go.
All right. As this obviously That's
And I'm I'm being nice compared to how Pisco is going to treat
you if you say this [__] around him. This is going
to be my fourth cycle. This is going to be my fourth presidential
cycle
watching the way that these online populist lefties
it just it seems to be getting worse,
not better. I'm being a bit more Okay. MAGA literally tried to
overthrow an election. At least At least some of these people
are pushing back. At least some of them are pushing back a little
bit, I I guess. General, you're talking about tankies, but I
mean just like gen Yeah, no, the person said Ogre Boy versus
Tim Pool.
And basically Hutch goes, well, I hate Ogre Boy equally to Tim
Pool. That Ogre Boy's beliefs are as harmful I think he causes
as much harm in the world as Tim
It's an insane proposition.
And just in general kind of the online
anti-Democratic Party left, I dislike them just as much as MAGA
at this point. It's just
years of this now.
I'm so done with it.
I'm so done with it. And >> Uh-huh. I told you guys what
they were going to do. I told you guys exactly what they were
going to do. These people are so transparent.
I told you exactly what they were going to do. What could it
be that he told us? Cuz I know that he said, hey, don't vote
for us then. And then they're like, okay, don't hold it against
us. And then Hutch held it against them. So, I wonder what his
prediction What was his prediction about the lefties, the
Yeah, just any of the the lefty types.
They're so obvious about what they're
And they rely on people's ignorance to galvanize support online,
but it's so obvious what they're doing.
What is it obvious that they do?
Maybe more than a year ago. Okay. That they
The way that I look at them now is like I think that they found
an issue that they think is really good for them.
I think they think that like So for for It is good for them.
It's like one of the most quickly changing and escalating in
terms of importance issues that exists and they were on the right
side of it and have all of the authority on it. Have all the
authority to speak on it. Sound like the people who should be
in like they sound like the people who were
you know, they they knew it was going on before you. They've
all of the actual authority there. All of the cachet
So yes, they are trying to wheel and deal. They're trying to
basically make a thing of it, but liberals helped them, okay?
Third way helped them. Third way explicitly
came in and tried to make it an issue.
So it's not just them doing it. It's everybody doing it. For
years it was Medicare for all
and now it's Israel-Palestine.
And I think they look at polls showing support for Israel dropping
off of a cliff, especially He's going to he's going to do the
really dumb thing. He's going to do the really dumb thing.
And try to say, well, but uh people don't care about domestic
People don't care about foreign policy. People don't care about
foreign policy at all. They do when it affects their oil prices.
They do when it affects the cost of everything. They do when
it crashes the global economy. Yes, they do. They do. They absolutely
>> actually within the Democratic Party and they see those
polls and there's like a couple things going on
for them when they see those polls. For number one, they take
credit for that, which that is hilarious to me.
That they that they think that they did
Which is They did do that.
I And again, I can make this argument.
Like I But the unfortunate thing for him is I'm not going to
be talking about Hasan when I make this argument, so he's going
to be incapable of engaging with Do you want to know how the
Lefties did it? I'll tell you after I'll listen to him and then
I'll tell you exactly how the Lefties did it and the Lefties
should get credit because it's very obvious and Hutch doesn't
give a [__] Hutch's just going to try Hutch's engagement
is Twitter politics. Hey, not that I can blame him. My engagement
has lar- largely been for the past year and a half, 2 years,
Twitter politics. I'm getting a little more into it now, but
I've been, you know, more of a politics kind of guy, okay? So
I'm not even saying that's impossible, but he's trying to criticize
people who have a deep engagement and that's embarrassing. Just
I mean that is amazing to me that they think that. Oh, is he
going to make an argument on why they didn't do it or Support
for Israel
just went down down down down down
and it kept going down and it kept getting worse the more things
escalated
in Gaza.
And How do you know about it escalating in Gaza? How do you know
about what they're doing in Gaza? How do you know about what
they're doing in Lebanon? How do you know about all of this stuff?
I'm going to tell you
guess who in response to the 2024 election or sorry, not in response,
but just before the 2024 election founded a news agency
almost explicitly to go and cover the Middle East and explicitly
everything going on in Israel.
Oh, like Ryan Grim and Jeremy Scahill?
Like the people who came out and did all of the journalism have
have done the lion's share, a massive chunk of the journalism
to publish exactly what Israel's been doing and get everybody
to know what their crimes are, what they've been doing, keeping
track of this for a long time. Yes, Mehdi Hasan standing on business,
getting banned from MSNBC, getting fired from MSNBC and founding
Zeteo. These are people who are Leftists or at least Left-leaning,
significantly Left-leaning and they risked everything, they've
lost a lot and they went all in because they thought this was
a moral issue and they thought it was the right thing to do.
Right? And yeah yeah, exactly. You, by the way, continue to say
this was a nothingburger. This was a nothing issue. There's nothing
you could do about it. These people actually moved the needle.
So it's shameful to me. It feels like you should be shamed. I
feel shame, okay? It's a shameful act to go and say, well, these
people didn't do anything. They're taking credit for it. They
didn't do anything. Yes, they did.
Yes, they did. It's possible that if Dropsite is never found
founded, if Zeteo is never founded, that you have significantly
less idea of what's going on in Israel, how it maps together,
how you get any validation on any of the clips you see, right?
You might have no idea what's going on. Yes, so the Lefties did
do this and the contemporaries of Crystal Ball did this. So when
they take credit for it, you say, "Thank you for covering this
stuff." When I said it wasn't an issue, when I said it wasn't
a big deal, when I said it wasn't a genocide, you founded a news
agency to go and cover this stuff because you cared. Thank you.
Thank you, Ryan Grim. I appreciate you, Ryan Grim. Thank you,
Ryan Grim.
That's what you should [__] say.
Anyway, we continue. >> No, you fast forward to to early
about a year ago, actually. It's about a year ago now.
Uh Trump takes office,
takes off the gloves completely, doesn't try to rein in Israel
at all. They do an 11-week blockade,
you know, near famine, near mass starvation event.
And so they like like instead of instead of understanding like
why the public
more and more was slowly turning on
the Left just they're claiming credit for it as if their online
activism and the student protests
And it just
>> You can see like he he literally
Maybe is this just
I can't even tell if he's dumb or if it's like intentional cuz
he's picking like He's basically trying to pick the least consequential
things. Even though the student protests I think were consequential
because of the Trump overreach against them, but he's trying
to pick the least consequential things to fight with.
Why don't you pick their strongest argument, which is things
like Dropsite, things like Zeteo, forming these new news agencies
and covering this conflict
Providing people with this media. We're just going to pretend.
We're just going to pretend that like, oh well, actually they
didn't do anything.
Painful. Shameful behavior, man. Same thing with the Cuba [__]
right?
Ryan Grim, bunch of people, they go they go to Cuba, they try
to take aid there and everybody freaks out and says they're getting
kids killed.
Shameful
behavior.
As soon as Isn't it crazy that for so long the Left was like
mocked and shamed for not engaging? And then on the basis I think
on the from the impetus provided by the Israel-Palestine conflict,
the genocide going on in Gaza, I think a lot of these people
actually buckled down, got invested, got very effective in what
they were doing and now everybody's saying they should be out
of the coalition. Isn't that interesting? As soon as As soon
as some Lefties start getting actually organized, start start
buckling down, start putting their [__]
people go, "Oh, wait. No, these guys need to be out. Get them
out. Get them out. Get them out. Get them out."
Crazy. were the reason that the public turned on Israel and not
like Israel's own conduct. The reason people turn on Israel is
because the longer this thing went out and the more buildings
were destroyed and the more people that were
Okay. What did it look like when Crystal Ball had this conversation?
What did it look like? Why did she know what it look like? Why
was her calibration to the issue appropriate and yours wasn't?
That's the thing. Right? She understands. She knows what's going
on. She is appropriately calibrated right
It's everybody else who's looking at this, not looking at what
Gaza looked like when she did this interview,
not looking at the situation there, and you're all judging her
for her attitude. You could say, well, the Lefties didn't do
anything. Well, you're judging her right now for freaking out
during the Trump's the Trump administration writing that blank
check to Israel to do whatever they wanted, right? That's what
she's freaking out about. That's what she's upset about.
She's not upset that like, hey, Israel's doing a ground operation.
She's not saying, "Oh, how do you sleep at night because Israel
just started ground operations like 3 days after October 7th."
Okay, we continue. We keep going. Um people are not going to
support that forever, you know. A- after October 7th,
Israel obviously was going to respond to that and so people I
think
there was a lot more support for Israel right after October 7th
in the in the immediate kind of months that followed where it's
like, well, obviously they're going to retaliate. Obvi- Yeah,
this is um this is I actually know what it is now. And I I believe
this for Hutch. I don't believe this for a lot of the other people,
but for Hutch,
uh he's like literally when he watches this, he
hears Crystal Ball talking to him. How do you sleep at night?
How do you sleep at night? I think you have to tell yourself
this. If you have a conscience, I think you have to tell yourself
this that there's nothing you could do. You did everything you
could and these people were unreasonable. I think that's a different
form of rationalization
of this event that I think Hutch is engaging in. Hutch needs
to think that he couldn't have done anything, that he did everything
he could and that these people were all unreasonable because
one, they have this criticism of him as
And two,
like you do actually get to the point where it's like, dude,
I I actually I called out all the people who were pointing this
out. I I was very mad at the person who knew what was going on.
And that's what you have to really understand here is Alyssa
Slotkin, she's asked and she says, "I see all the military briefs
on this area. I know what's going on." And Crystal says like,
"How do you sleep at night?"
I can't. I I feel like I'm not doing enough. How could you as
somebody who's in power, how can you sleep at night? Cuz like
I I spend every waking hour covering this or I spend all my free
time looking into this and I don't think I'm doing enough. How
do you sleep at night? Cuz I don't. I already don't. Or whatever
the [__] she said, okay? Obviously, they're going
do everything in their power to make sure that Hamas is never
able to do that ever again. And so,
you know, you can forgive a certain amount of destruction. You
can You can forgive a certain amount of collateral damage in
the pursuit of that kind of of those kinds of like This is a
totally cut This is if you're friends with people, which the
US and Israel are friends.
When your friend suffers like a tragedy and they're feeling like
they need
it's your job as a real friend to talk them down from that. To
explain that that's not right and that needs to not be what you
do. You need to not like compound whatever damage has been done.
Right? That is the That is the rhetoric you go to them with.
You don't go, "Well, yeah, I guess you could like I guess you
could go do retribution on like two or three people,
but then you got to stop." That's not That's not how you start
it, man. security measures.
But if that goes on for two plus years, you know, two and a half
years now,
people are going to stop supporting that at some point, especially
with the sheer amount of death and destruction in Gaza.
But this you know, so anyways, like the online left see sees
these numbers and number one, they take they take credit for
it.
And number two, they think that this issue will be the thing
that will help
It should help them. That's the other thing. It should help them.
Dropsite,
breaking points, they should get massive social capital for being
on the right side of this issue and dealing with all of the smears
of them that they had to to accurately report on this issue.
You, Hutch, and me, Hutch, we both sat on the sidelines in so
many ways, okay? That like I I look at this stuff and I'm like,
"Man, I I kind of stopped covering this [__] and
I feel bad about it." You should feel bad about it. That should
be your primary emotion. I didn't do my job. I covered the news.
I mean, I started doing drama stuff and I got out of politics
basically when this whole war broke out. I started doing like
this online thing and it was different, okay? But I I feel bad.
You should feel bad. That should be the primary thing you feel
is like, "I wasn't invested in this. It felt like complicated
and it felt like it was very high stakes and I didn't really
want to get any more invested in it than I was." That's how you
should feel. You shouldn't feel like, "Oh, these people are trying
to take credit for it." They should. They should take credit
for it. They were on the right side of the
Tell me why they shouldn't take credit for it. Tell me why they
shouldn't take credit for accurately reporting on this when it
cost social and economic capital to do so.
Political capital. It cost everything for these people.
Hasan has been smeared as anti as Hasan has been smeared and
continues to be smeared as an anti-Semite for covering it. It
has costs.
Like primary
more moderate Democrats.
So, it was Medicare for all for like 10 years where they made
it about them They made the litmus test of their movement was
support for Medicare for all.
And they had these delusional fantasies that everybody in the
Dude, his uh his chat is like actually doing a little better
than I thought it
The forever war concept is pretty much baked in. Ab- absolutely,
obviously. It only took about 100,000 civilian deaths, which
these people were constantly putting a spot- spotlight on. Who
put the spotlight and correctly labeled Israel's actions? The
left. Yeah, okay. I I don't know if he's getting I don't know
if there's just a bunch of randoms, like a bunch of random lefties
watching this, but holy [__] this is bad, man. Oh,
sure, Hasan lost his Twitch ads, right? All over anti-Semitism.
Um that whole campaign is over
Man, I I should have saved this Notsorry clip from a long while
back, but it was talking about how her like what her philosophy
was
around admitting wrongdoing and how you just shouldn't never
You shouldn't ever admit wrongdoing and how she's never going
to admit wrongdoing on the internet cuz it makes you look bad.
I'm like, "Dude, how do you How do you live like that? How could
you be a content creator like that and talk about anything consequential?"
Like if you never want to admit wrongdoing, but you cover like
fantasy books or something. And when when you get like a reader
or an analysis or prediction wrong for the next book, you like
get it wrong, you never want to admit wrongdoing.
I get it. That's fine. But you're covering politics.
A A essential function of politics has to be some analysis of
where you were wrong and how you're going to be better going
forward. If you If that is totally absent, how in the world can
you be a political actor?
It It's ins- It's preposterous. It's [__] insane.
It's completely [__] insane. It's It's like crazy.
And I I do get it cuz it feels like
it feels like people can go back and make fun of you. But like
you I I just don't understand how you could Cuz people You know,
sometimes Our boy and Straight Rated both come in and throw tweets
of me calling people anti-Semitic. Like um Hasan's orbiters,
right? And And I'm like, "Yeah, I I was wrong." Although some
I'm sure in some of those cases, Mike said some stuff that's
like crossing It's close to crossing the line. Although I think
I kind of took his side on it, actually. But even then, I I basically
just go, "I was wrong." Yeah, I was wrong. I don't need to delete
those posts. I was wrong. You can be wrong.
You can be wrong, man. Um Matt, specifically in this one instance,
it was the demonic ethnicity thing. And I I felt like he was
joking, and so I said it was anti-Semitic, but it wasn't like
It was like a different um
It's like a different analysis you do. I was just trying to accurate
accurately explain what he was doing. It was anti-Semitism, though.
Anyway, we continue. Let's continue on with our boy Hutchook,
okay? We're going to continue on with him.
country like really wants Medicare for
the specific language of like Bernie's bill, like everybody Everybody
like really wants it, and so they're going to use that to primary
like all these Democrats that are kind of more moderate, and
that didn't happen. You know, they they talked it up and they
talked it up and they talked it up. That was the whole point
of like force the vote. The stupidest thing I've ever heard my
life was force the vote. And uh the whole point of force the
vote was to get like a hit list, like a political hit list. Not
for like,
you know, murdering them, but voting them out of office. Like
we need to get all these Democrats on the record. And then everyone
who votes against
Medicare for all, we're going to primary
and uh that didn't happen. And so now they're doing the same
thing with Israel. Like I told you guys
I told you guys a year ago.
They're going to use Israel. They're going to make Israel a flashpoint
issue.
And they're going to They're going to use it as a referendum
on They're going to use the midterms as a ref-
Again, just totally It's totally disconnected. It's totally disconnected
from whether or not they were correct about Israel. Right? We
just We're just not going to have it connected at all. He's just
going to say, "Well, I told you that they were going to do this."
It's like um Bro, he is like Doug Ford Sorry, he's like Rob Ford
right now going into the Toronto mayoral election, the last one
he won, okay? And he goes to his brother Doug and he says, "Listen,
I told you guys" And actually, he's doing a press conference
to his Let's just say to whoever's party is, okay? It's It's
Rob Ford. And he goes, "Guys, I told you that they were going
to make me smoking crack an issue, and here it is."
Like as if somebody can't even just enjoy a little crack, all
right? But I told you that they were going to do this. They were
going to make me smoking crack an issue, and here it is. After
everything, it rears its ugly head. They're going to try to make
me smoking crack an issue. It's crazy. And it's like, "Bro, you
actually shouldn't smoke crack if you're the mayor of a city."
That's just That's just facts. Hey, you're the mayor. Don't smoke
crack.
So, it's what If it's disconnected from whether or not they're
correct, you're not saying anything. You're actually kind of
just sweeping for yourself. It's crazy. It's crazy to watch.
referendum on Israel [snorts] and on like moderate
who still support, you know, Iron Dome funding or something.
Oh, sorry. The other point of that is like foundationally, bringing
up the crack issue with Rob Ford is important. Hey, you have
a major failing as a mayor. I need to address it. Likewise with
the Israel issue. You have a major failing as a politician if
you have been supporting this blindly the whole time because
of how the like everything's working in terms of lobbying and
stuff. You have a major failing. You lack moral clarity. You
do not have the morals required to operate with the power you
hold. That That's just That's the way it is, man. Anyway, I I'm
going to back it up cuz I've kind of broken him up a little bit,
but we're going to go 20 seconds back here. They're going to
use Israel. They're going to make Israel a flashpoint issue.
And they're going to They're going to use it as a referendum
on They're going to use the midterms as a referendum on Israel
[snorts] and on like moderate
who still support, you know, Iron Dome funding or something like
that.
And that's exactly what they're doing. That's exactly what they're
doing. That's exactly what we've been watching them do.
And it's just getting more intense, and
Dude, that's justified, dude. Bro, I think a lot of these This
guy's like a Hutch sub. This guy's like a Hutch sub and he's
sitting here and it's like, "Dude, yeah, that's justified." That's
justified. Yeah, I'm sorry. They were just correct. I don't know
like what Bro, could you imagine if like the polar ice caps melted
and environmentalists came in like lefty environmentalist types
and ran on that the fact that they were right about like uh climate
change and environmentalism and they were like attacking uh right
Sorry, right-wing environmentalists cuz there are some conservative
environmentalist types, okay? And they come in and they start
running against the the MAGA types and the neocons who constantly
pushed oil, constantly pushed fossil fuels, and they say, "These
guys were wrong."
Well, yeah, you look like you're Yeah, you're going to run on
the issue you have credibility on.
Well, I'm just at my wits' end with these people. I I I just
find them to be so dis- destructive.
And so yeah, I dislike them equally
as I dislike MAGA. They're just in
I feel like most people moved on from Israel-Palestine. My mind
there
Um He says that on a show where the two highest viewership streamers
in like that sphere of people are both watching it a several
almost a year-old interview about Israel-Palestine to criticize
it on the grounds of Israel-Palestine. most in the same >> like
we're basically done. I mean, I one of the most proudest moments
that I had in my last election where I just won on the same ballot
as Donald Trump was that I won a majority of voters in Michigan.
We have a large population and I won Dearborn, Dearborn Heights,
and Hamtramck, the three Muslim-dominated cities. Um Trump won
two out of the three. So, I think the thing that um I would push
back on is the voters I would say six years, but certainly in
this last election, other than this issue because >> Remember
Michigan, largest like Arab population I think in the United
States, right? Dearborn is obviously a hot topic, right? So,
this is like the singular most contentious issue that she has
to navigate and this is what they decide we're going to fight
Because we're going to fight you on this, right? >> when
all of your constituents are like, >> Yeah, yeah, it's
yeah. Is it personal? I'm a Middle East analyst by training.
And so, what I tried to do and why I think I managed to win both
those communities is call balls and strikes literally up to this
week on what's going on. So, I feel like you can't simultaneously
claim leftists were not the one influencing opinions on Israel
while also saying the left has immense influence in online discourse.
That would be another huge thing to that would be another huge
point that I didn't even make, but yeah, sure. There's like so
many different dimensions along which Hutch's analysis is completely
fundamentally broken. You can't even think of all of them. It's
just broken top-to-bottom. It's awful. I It's complicated.
It's complicated. I think
the damage that the online left do is to create apathy.
And so, the Israel attacks are in service of a larger kind of
populist
like attack from a populist framing
on Dem
I Okay.
So, man, we could go more into this. They make I think They they
they create apathy. They spread apathy. I would say that is
But the issue is
essentially it let's say they're correct and I do believe they've
been correct, right? About how angry you should be, how upset
you should be about what's going on, right? They've been correct
and your way of characterizing that is that it's building apathy.
This is in essence the 2016 conundrum again where people are
out of work, the the Rust Belt has been hollowed out, there's
no more manufacturing there. They blame Democrats. They blame
the Democrats they've been voting for, right? And there is apathy
there. There's two ways you can deal with that. You can keep
gaslighting them and telling them to vote for you.
We seen how that's turned out. Leads to 2016, Donald Trump winning
the presidency, okay? Or you can admit where you were wrong and
try to come up with some policy to rectify that problem.
Yo, all That was our bad. We didn't see it going in this way.
Here's how we're going to try to fix it. But oh my god, you have
no idea how people will be if you just keep gaslighting them
and never acknowledge any wrongdoing, never acknowledge any of
their issues, never acknowledge that they had a good point. Because
with NAFTA, the issue was free trade agreements were better for
the whole economy.
And we could quibble over whether that's, you know, capitalism,
you know, increasing the wealth gap, all of this stuff. That's
not super important. The The argument is it's good for the overall
economy. GDP go up. Nobody disagrees that GDP go up with free
trade agreements, okay?
But what these people were told is it's not going to really affect
you that much. It's just going to help you. Your your life's
going to be better.
And then when a lot of people's lives got worse, there was no
answer. There was basically just pretending that they didn't
do anything wrong and then proposing new free trade free trade
agreements, TPP.
Very, very big mistake.
Do not do that.
All right, we'll go back to where he starts talking about apathy,
okay? >> complicated. I think
the damage that the online left do is to create apathy.
And so, the Israel attacks are in service of a larger kind of
populist
like attack from a populist framing
on Democrats. So, like the Israel issue is just one of many issues
that the left use to
really like savagely attack
any Democrat that doesn't meet their purity test, which happens
to be about 95% of Democrats. And And to
Did I miss a sudden shift in the Hutch audience? Conduit here
going, wait, why are people pointing out that like they were
correct.
Why Why Why aren't we doing that our gaslighting thing? Why don't
we just going like we're the huge victims? Democrats are the
victims actually and the left was totally wrong. Even though
they're correctly right on the issue, they were Sorry, they were
totally right on the issue. They're totally correct. Even knowing
that, we're going to pretend that we're the victims here.
Isn't that what we do in this chat, guys? Don't we pretend we're
the >> To be clear, I'm not saying that the left had no
impact
on Israel's declining approval. I'm not saying that.
Um but I am saying that it's
to claim credit
for the public writ large like moving away from Israel.
Not Did the online left contribute to
in their own way? Yeah, I would say so. Okay, so you're saying
nothing.
You're just saying literally nothing.
You're doing You're doing a quibble cuz you hate them like getting
points on this. So, you're just quibbling. Got it. >> For
sure. Got it. But the substance of their contribution I think
is to further foment apathy among younger voters. Like the online
left I think are
most influential and this is just a guess. I'm not This is just
vibes.
Um I think they're most influential with like voters under 30,
under 35.
I think when you're when you're in your young that like young
adult phase of your life,
there's a further risk of
this kind of sentiment calcifying.
You know, so early early apathy towards the Democratic Party,
I think they're Okay, so now oh early apathy towards the Democratic
Party. Okay. Now, look at these influencers who these left-wing
influencers, what is calcifying in their thoughts about the right-wing
party, the Republicans?
Cuz I've never seen Hasan say like a good thing about the Republicans.
I've never seen Kyle say a good thing about the Republicans.
I see them on the Republicans constantly. So, any harm they're
doing by pointing out true facts about the Democratic Party has
to be offset by the fact that one, they've never presented the
the Republicans as better. At worst, I think the worst it ever
got was Hasan saying, I don't even know if it would be different
under the other party, which was stupid, but regardless, okay?
That's the That's the worst it's ever gotten. And there was like
a moment where that happened. But otherwise, they just [__]
on the Republicans all the time. There's a risk of that like
and and then like bleeding into your adult life.
Um And I think apathy is a is a big a big problem. It's been
a big problem for young voters for quite some time, but I think
they're just making it worse. And You know what the apathy is
from? The apathy is from seeing the direction of the country
and seeing that nothing they do changes it. That's what the apathy
is coming from. So, when they can all see the war crimes that
are happening from Israel, they're watching Gaza be blown up
brick by brick because the the people they're they're, you know,
subscribed to are covering it and they see that despite the fact
that this is happening, obvious war crimes, obvious genocide,
nothing changes. Nothing their voice doesn't matter.
Have you considered perhaps
not explicitly making it so that you are so slow to react to
to uh what do you say? You You're so slow to react to developing
situations
that they are correct to be apathetic. They believe that you
will do nothing and then you are defending doing nothing. You
are saying, why did you guys get so mad about us doing nothing?
Why do you feel apathetic? Don't feel apathetic. You need to
watch us do nothing about this genocide and you need to be excited
about it.
I I don't know who you're selling with that pitch, man. Who are
you selling? Who's buying that? Yeah, I totally me in the ass
and never let me complain about it. Yeah, that's what I want
to do. I'm going to be a member of the Democratic Party. I want
to be a Democrat.
Yeah, that's not Nobody's signing up for that, man. I hope you
got something better. I hope you got a a plan B. You got another
sales pitch cuz that sounds terrible. Not that I wouldn't vote
Democrat if I were in the States. I absolutely would. But holy
[__] this is the worst marketing I've ever seen in
my entire life. Actually, we were wrong on the issue substantively.
These people had were seeing what was going on and were upset
about it and we are justifying their apathy by saying no, it
was the right decision to not do anything about
>> Apathy [clears throat] is a is a big a big problem.
It's been a big problem for young voters for quite some time,
but I think they're just making it worse. And so, So, it's a
bit nuanced. I don't I I hope I didn't worm out of your question
there, but I think I addressed it. I very much disagree with
you, but I appreciate your clarification on your perspective.
Okay, there you go. You're playing loose the left directly has
credit for the public calling it a genocide. You're being vague
by saying moved away from Israel. I don't think I'm being vague.
I'm talking about the numbers, the approval numbers. When we
look at a a graph of like how the public and then broken down
by party, you know, Republican,
uh Democrat.
You are being vague. You are not making a a solid declaration
of what you think is going to happen. numbers. When we look at
a a graph of like how the public and then broken down by party,
you know, Republican, Independent,
uh Democrat. When we look at the graph over time, the support
for Israel
goes down. And within the Democratic Party, the support for Israel
had been going down for years preceding
October 7th. It had already been going
Yeah. And to your other point, I don't
Why would that be? Why Why do you think that would be, Hutch?
I'm just curious. Do you think that could be from like people
covering
how Israel was treating Gazans over time? >> Listen, I
don't think the online left And people covering that and talking
about it? Focusing on the language of genocide was the thing
that what that most contributed to public approval
How many times does he get to walk back and make more specific
his statement that he made in the first place? He realized how
stupid the first thing he said was, and so he's walking it back
bit by bit. So it was at first it was the left did not The left
didn't help. They They try to take credit for this. That's insane
that they take credit for this. They didn't do anything. And
then he's walking it back slowly. He's like, "Well, no, they
helped, but it just wasn't that much." Well, actually, the idea
of the focus of the on the language of genocide and how much
that helped.
At some point he's going to go, "I just I just don't like I just
don't like online lefties.
Leave me alone." moving away from Israel.
I don't think that was the thing. I think it was the image of
like the images and videos of the death and the destruction and
people don't like generally like seeing Where did those come
from? kids dying.
Oh, I thought you weren't supposed to talk about the kids dying.
I thought that was like you're using the kids as a shield. Oh,
you're using the kids as a shield. And
I think also just the what was happening, not just images, but
like what was happening. And then more and more people began
to you know, I think probably more people now are are aware Oh,
Hutch Hutch just real quick. Could you show me CNN broadcasting
all of the death and destruction? Could you show show me CNN
broadcasting all the dead kids? Was CNN doing that? Was MSNBC
doing that? Was Fox News doing that? Or was it like
like mostly left-leaning people on social media who were sharing
these things and and amplifying this and he's he's basically
just he's almost entirely conceded the argument now. I didn't
even you know, I wasn't even going to make the argument about
social media and obviously it's mostly lefty people who are continuing
to point this or put put this out and and highlight it, right?
I just went to Ryan Grim and Drop Site News because that's like
something that is incredibly consequential and is probably driving
the the attribution of the clips and probably driving new stuff
being released, right? That was my argument. But yeah, obviously
all of social media being used as a vehicle for showing this
footage for showing the war crimes. Yeah, that's largely up to
online lefties, the exact people you just you despise. Apparently
over saying it was a genocide which you now concede it is. It's
crazy. where like at least the 21st century history of Israel.
But again, I wouldn't fight you on the idea that the online left
contributed
in their own way to public approval for Israel going down. I
think they did contribute to that. But taking credit for something
and taking credit for contributing to something are two different
things. I don't think anybody is going I don't think anybody
believes that if Israel had gone done a quick ground operation,
killed like 20,000 people and pulled back without blowing up
all of the housing and hospitals in Gaza. I don't think people
people would go Oh, yeah, we I I don't think people think that
this still would have flipped the same way. Like they don't think
they were responsible. They think they were responsible for getting
the messaging out, getting people to look at it. Which is a contribution.
But for Israel's actual genocide
of course nothing changes.
Of course. But like nobody's saying Nobody's saying regardless
of whether genocide happened, regardless of whether they went
totally insane in Gaza, we flipped the everybody on Israel. No.
What's a but for? It's saying without this happening.
If that if that was confusing language, I'll try to restrict
it a little bit. Without the actual genocide, without the actual
operation, the actual war crimes
of course none of this happens. Yeah, you of course.
I think the distinction
Um Lawson with $10, they're not even correct on Israel-Palestine
and I'm worried that the demand for a massive Israel policy change
comes from the moral bullying as opposed to actual knowledge
of the region.
Um well, I mean it just you know, it depends on what they're
talking about. That's a little broad.
I mean, yeah, Kanye.
That's another thing. Kanye West I think
contributed Oh god. Oh god, please stop.
Wait. Contri Hold on.
Hold on. He can't say There's no way to win this. Either side
of this whatever he's going to say is going to be the I've ever
heard in my life. And look at his smug face as he goes to say.
He is so smug about this point he's about to make. I swear to
god if he says Kanye contributed to knowledge of Gaza when Kanye
was just explicitly anti-Semitic and barely even referred to
Gazans at
Like it was like 99% anti-Semitism, direct anti-Semitism and
almost nothing to do with Gaza. If he says that, he's stupid.
If he says Kanye contributed anti-Semitism, well, that's obvious.
But if he says Kanye didn't do enough or kept people off of the
issue, that's also stupid. So I I don't even know anywhere you
go here, it's all dumb. That's a little broad. Please please
>> yeah, Kanye.
That's another thing. Kanye West I think
contributed
more to uh
Are you congratulating Kanye West
Hitler right now and the awareness that brought to the Israel-Palestine
issue.
>> Dude, I just I actually don't even know what What are
we doing? I In what universe are you going to because the entire
reason they've been arguing that Hassan wasn't effective and
a bunch of other people weren't effective is because it was actually
increasing anti-Semitism in a way that it was like increasing
more anti-Semitism versus helping Israel-Palestine versus helping
the Gazans in any way. And now you've got a guy who's just essentially
doing only anti-Semitism.
And you're going to say, "Congrats to Kanye. My hat is off to
Kanye West." Holy
man.
I mean, yeah, Kanye.
That's another thing. Kanye West I think
contributed
more to
uh like anti-Israel sentiment
than the collectively like the entire online left. Like I think
you know, wow. Thank you, Hutch. I think what he did was like
very
What's the word? Insidious?
I mean, that guy has a lot of influence just all on his own.
Reminder that no rhetoric online, no rhetoric at all online has
changed anything. It's been Israel's action. And now he's trying
to say, "Well, Kanye did way more."
Did Kanye talk about Israel's actions?
In fact, I think Kanye is back on board with Israel at this point.
This is
Bro, I have How do you How are you watching this? How I just
say it again. How are you watching? How are How is anybody watching?
He's probably got like 500, 600, maybe 1,000 viewers across two
platforms while streaming this. People watch it. People actually
watch it. He did have Netanyahu. Maybe maybe that's what Hutch
is arguing, okay? Netanyahu drew so much attention
to Israel.
Don't even, dude.
I can't. Proceeding in a gradual, subtle way but with harmful
effects. Yeah. Kanye has since apologized to the community and
made peace with Yeah, I saw that. I I saw that he did it conveniently
like right before he started to sell an album.
So there's that. So let's let's talk a little bit more about
that. But I think I think it's important, right? If you're going
to push on me then I I think like there's there's one of us that's
had an election and had to appeal to my voters and win. And so
it doesn't surprise me at all that Mr. Mondaire won. Um or actually
I I didn't I didn't know his name. I didn't know much about him
until he won, but because I think this issue is motivating people
in a very visceral and personal way. But it's not the only issue
that my voters in Michigan care about.
extremely focused on this, but that doesn't always represent
the majority. And I think if I Mhm. Mhm. Mhm. That's
Back company with $5, also I think a big part of it was the right
looking for a scapegoat for Trump's catastrophic admin
Because by and large right-wing attitudes have not shifted anywhere
near the same amount. So no. Immediately no.
Immediately wrong. Immediately no. Blaming Israel for contri
uh controlling Trump. That's an interesting theory. Um let me
see Let me just look over time.
Help me. Republicans have shifted, but this is because they've
been saying no new wars and they've gone to a new war. That's
why they've shifted. Cuz I know I've seen these polls showing
like over time sentiment
towards Israel. Dude, that was a crazy nose breaker right there.
If somebody can help me find a poll
cuz I know I've seen these polls showing
He's got like the finger there. He's got like the the fingers
ready to go. He's got it like He's like, "I did that gesture.
I got to use that that [__] now?" I towards
I I
>> Why? Why would you do that? What? What are we doing,
guys? What are we doing here, man?
approval of Israel went down for Republican voters. I want to
know when that moment was. What in the heck? What the heck? Why
are people so against Israel if all it takes
to make a monthly paycheck is to post support for Israel? He
stared He stared right at the camera. That was a sign of dominance,
okay? That was a signal of dominance
over his audience, okay? He He just stared right into the camera
while he double double fingered his nose, okay?
This is what they think anyways. Wait, what? Why are people so
against Israel? If all it takes to make a monthly paycheck is
to post support for Israel, I'm a little
little confused by that one. I might be too dumb That's uh neuroticism
right there, Hutch. They're saying these people all say that
everyone who supports Israel gets paid for it. If it If that
was true, then why why would you not get paid? Why don't more
people support Israel if that was all it If If that was all it
took? That's just That's just JN. That person is freaking out
over something that nobody said and nobody cares about. Okay?
You got to got to let that go by, okay? Just like you're a boxer
with your head weaves, okay? You're weaving your head, you just
let that slip by you, okay? It's a jab. It's a jab. Whoa, we're
out of the way. We're out of the way. I dude, I'm doing all these
actions and you guys don't get it, but I don't understand that.
One day we'll have a
I don't know to what extent Nick Fuentes
influenced
the right-wing I like um
opinion of Israel.
Hutch, what would you ask Hassan?
Like if I
uh like if I was sitting in a room with him, if I was on a live
stream with him, I don't know, that's a good question.
There's a few questions There's a few things that pop pop into
mind, but if I had to ask one question, Oh. I think right now
I would ask him how he can How is he capable of making a harm
reduction calculus
when it comes to Israel versus Hamas,
but he seemingly can't can't make a the the same kind of harm
reduction calculus when it comes to like Newsom versus Vance.
Okay, can somebody send me if Matt's here? Matt, can you send
me the clip for the like him basically saying, "Of course I'd
vote Gavin Newsom over I'd eventually vote Democrat." I'm not
saying I won't vote for any Democrat. I'm not even saying I won't
vote for Gavin Newsom at all, but as it stands currently, the
way he's presented himself, he's done nothing to earn not only
my vote, but the votes of millions of Americans. I'm willing
to play hardball with them and say like, "Look, I'll I'll hold
my vote back." But the reality of the matter is, if you're asking
me sincerely like, "Do you think that um Gavin Newsom is going
to be better than J.D. Vance?" Of course. I mean, this is not
something just like Kamala Harris is objectively going to be
better than Donald Trump.